[Applaus]
[Musik]
japan wir dazu in ländern wie uns in
vielerlei hinsicht immer wieder aufs
neue überraschen dazu gehört vor allem
die japanische politik die bei uns
regelmäßig großes erstaunen auslöst denn
ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht liebe soll
politik fans seit dem untergang des
japanischen kaiserreich in der anderen
40 hat ja wann 31 verschiedene
premierminister dies bedeutet eine
durchschnittliche anzahl von gut zwei
jahren und wer nun mutmaßt dass diese
üblicherweise kürzer ist als in anderen
demokratien verehrt auch in japan gelten
die weitverbreiteten vier jahre aber wie
premierminister dort scheint ähnlich
häufig zu purzeln die beim hsv die
cheftrainer dennoch ist es erstaunlich
dass ein wesentliches merkmal des
japanischen politischen systems seine
stabilität ist
[Musik]
dafür ist vor allem die tatsache
verantwortlich dass eine partei das
politische geschehen geradezu dominiert
es handelt sich um die
liberaldemokratische partei die in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten meistens in
regierungschef stellte gegen sie hat
japans opposition traditionell einen
sehr schweren stand selbstverständlich
wäre es trotz dieser einseitigen
machtverteilung falsch von einer
diktatur zu sprechen japan ist in der
praxis eine demokratie die auf der
grundlage der organen der wichtigsten
politischen partei funktioniert ok ich
kann die verwirrung die grade es in
euren köpfen herrscht förmlich spüren
lassen sich mit ein paar
hintergrundinformationen erklären er im
land der aufgehenden sonne werden
politische auseinandersetzungen
hauptsächlich abseits der öffentlichkeit
zum beispiel auf den fluren und in den
hinterzimmern der beteiligten
institutionen ausgetragen viele
undurchsichtige machtspiele sorgen für
ein gemenge aus freiwilligen oder
unfreiwilligen personalwechseln
stichwort misstrauensanträge und
vorgezogenen wahlen
[Musik]
der politiker um den es in diesem video
geht ist der aktuelle premierminister
sein name ist vom ioc china und arcandor
über 2021 an die macht nachdem sein
vorgänger josef sogar nach nur gut einem
jahr im amt zurückgetreten war übrigens
gehören beide der bereits erwähnten
übermächtigen liberal demokratischen
partei an spannend ist allerdings dass
japans neuer regierungschef über einen
gänzlich anderen charakter verfügt als
seine vorgänger der letzten jahre er ist
ein extrem erfahrener politiker seit
1993 ist er mitglied des
repräsentantenhauses und unter dem
ehemaligen regierungschef shinzo abe war
außenminister seine große erfahrung
unterscheidet den deutlich vom neuen
südkoreanischen präsidenten lee seung
yul der jüngst ins amt kam und über den
fußball politik bald ein eigenes video
drehen werden gilt im gegensatz zum
japaner die china als politischer
außenseiter
[Musik]
und obwohl die china politisch in der
tradition des ehemaligen premiers a
besteht wird von ihm eine vollkommen
neue innen und wirtschaftspolitik
erwartet er will die von abb eingeführte
aber enorm ex strategie der dingen und
japans kapitalismus neu erfinden sein
ziel ist die einführung einer
japanischen volkswirtschaft dh eines
eigens aus japan zugeschnittenen
marktwirtschaftlichen mutes dass allein
liebe wieso allerdings zu short leg
schon recht spannend und wir werden euch
natürlich verraten was ist damit auf
sich hatte aber
[Musik]
haltet euch fest dann geschieht das
wirtschaftsreformen sind nichts
gegenüber dem was eine aussenpolitik
fortier hat geschieht ja geradezu
bahnbrechende pläne mit einem besonderen
fokus auf eine drastische erhöhung der
beteiligung ausgaben damit wir einordnen
können was ist damit wirklich auf sich
hat und wieso dies eine echte
zeitenwende nicht nur eine rhetorische
darstellt lasst uns zuerst einen kurzen
blick auf japans außenpolitik der
letzten jahre werfen
[Musik]
das erwachen eines schlafenden riesen
während seiner amtszeit war shinzo abe
japans dienstältester dringe minister
davon besessen japan zurück auf die
internationale politische bühne zu
bringen um dies zu erreichen wird dann
die japanische regierung unter anderem
eine immer härtere position gegenüber
china und nordkorea ein zunehmend setze
sich als beschützer von verbündeten wie
taiwan in szene und führte nach dem
rückzug der usa auch das trans
pazifische freihandelsabkommen sieht die
cvp an mit anderen worten wir erlebten
einen der internationalen politik
ungewöhnlich aktives japan wollte und
nicht nur das er hat sich was sehr
wichtig für unser heutiges thema ist
dafür eingesetzt die militärische stärke
des landes zu erhöhen
darüber haben wir euch bereits bei
verschiedenen anderen gelegenheiten
berichtet auf abs betreiben ein hat die
japanische regierung versucht die
verfassung zu ändern um den artikeln zu
streichen der besagt dass japan ein
grundsätzlich pazifistisches land ist
wodurch der umfang und die finanzierung
der selbstverteidigungskräfte über
eingeschränkt wurden
den aufrichtigen streben nach einem auf
gerechtigkeit und ordnung gegründeten
internationalen frieden verzichtet das
japanische volk für alle seiten auf den
krieg als 1 fuß rechter nation und auf
die androhung oder ausübung von gewalt
als mittel zur beilegung internationale
streitigkeiten um das ziel des
vorhergehenden absatzes zu erreichen
werden keine land- see- und
luftstreitkräfte oder sonstige
kriegsmittel unterhalten wird eine recht
des staates zur kriegsführung wird nicht
anerkannt artikel 9 der japanischen
verfassung über viele jahre wurde
artikel 9 so interpretiert dass ein
verbot militärischer kapazitäten jesus
notwendigen mindestmaßes für eine
verteidigung gegen direkte angriffe
darstellte und nachdem shinzo abe dieses
verbot bereits teilweise aufgeweicht
hatte wildbiologe schieder nicht nur die
verfassungsreform vorantreiben sondern
noch viel weiter gehen und den
ehrgeizigen plan zur verbesserung der
militärischen fähigkeiten des landes
verabschieden
tatsächlich ist es genau das was die
legen gruppen seiner partei die ihn an
die spitze gebracht haben von ihm
fordern japans regierende ldp fordern
die verdoppelung des
verteidigungshaushalts die
militärausgaben japan sollen sich
allmählich den wert von 2 prozent des
bip annähern und ihn später sogar
überschreiten heute liegt dieser wert
bei etwa der hälfte und um euch eine
vorstellung über die dimensionen zu
geben dies würde den jährlichen militär
aus halle des landes von rund 54
milliarden auf als 100 milliarden dollar
aufblasen der neue premier hat sich das
ziel gesetzt über einen zeitraum von
fünf jahren zwischen 240 und 300
milliarden dollar zusätzlich für das
militär auszugeben und bei der
nationalen und internationalen
rüstungsunternehmen dürften vor dem
hintergrund dieser zahlen die sektkorken
nur so geknallt sein japan würde in der
welt rangliste der länder mit den
höchsten militärausgaben schlagartig von
rang 9 auf rang drei springen und
unweigerlich zur militärischen
supermacht werden geschieht das pläne
lösten auch in washington begeisterung
aus denn die usa würden eine befreundete
supermacht die den rivalen china in der
pazifikregion die stirn bietet sehr
begrüßen drücken moment erhält geschieht
durch die krieg in der ukraine in den
eher eine art turbo für seine politik
sieht und selbst sein vorgänger aber ist
teil dieses spiels
japans ldp bringt extreme in die
verfassungsreform ein und riskiert einen
gegenschlag der opposition und werde und
denkt der bezug zur ukraine wäre etwas
weit hergeholt sollte sich nicht
täuschen lassen
russland ist auch ein nachbarland japans
und wird dort auf große ereignisse der
letzten monate zunehmend als tyrann
wahrgenommen zudem ist der konflikt um
die kurilen bei dem japan mit russland
um territorialansprüche streitet seit
jahrzehnten ungelöst japan kritisiert
russlands schritt die friedensgespräche
über die umstrittenen kurilen inseln
gegen sanktionen zu beenden japan sagt
umstrittener inseln seien illegal von
russland besetzt japan bezeichnet vier
inseln um deren besitz es mit moskau
streitet in der neuesten version eines
diplomatischen berichts als illegal von
russland besetzt ihr seht also dass
japan allmählich eine immer wichtigere
und einflussreiche geostrategische rolle
in der asiatisch-pazifischen politik
einig über japans insel konflikte haben
sogar ein eigenes video gedreht das ich
euch hinter dem rechts und unten in der
video beschreibung verlinken werden aber
die außenpolitik ist natürlich nicht das
einzige feld in dem der neue japanische
regierungschef gehen die fußstapfen
seines großen vorgängers treten will da
ist auch ein starker befürworter einer
neupositionierung japans als führender
regionaler akteur in handelsfragen wir
haben euch bereits von seiner
führungsrolle beim ppp berichtet und vor
allem befürwortet er eine noch weitere
vertiefung der beziehungen zu den usa
sein politisches ziel ist jedoch weder
china noch amerika geschieht
traditionell eher schlechten beziehungen
zu südkorea die von gegenseitiger
unnachgiebigkeit und zahlreichen
provokationen geprägt waren einen ganz
neuen geist enger partnerschaft
einhauchen die korea beschließt
offiziell der scp tpp beizutreten um die
lieferketten zu stärken die jugend sagt
er werde den weitere zum quad positiv
prüfen wenn er eingeladen wird diese
beiden meldungen scheinen auf den ersten
blick nicht allzu beeindruckend zu sein
tauscht euch aber nicht liebe diesen
trick fans sie könnten der auftakt eine
gewaltige strategische verschiebung in
der region sein stellt euch mal vor was
entstehen könnte wenn japan und südkorea
ihre differenzen überwinden und stabile
partnerschaftliche beziehungen aufbauen
könnten beide kommen zusammen auf ein
bip von nato 7 billionen dollar und
sollte china seine pläne zur steigerung
des japanischen dem osten könne gebe das
duo auf etwa 150 milliarden dollar
jährlich für das militär eine japanisch
südkoreanische militär politische
kooperation würde definitiv einen
schlagkräftigen asiatischen gegen block
zu china bilden lasst uns diesen aspekt
etwas näher beleuchten
[Musik]
regling über das war immer noch doppelt
so viel für sein militär ausgeben als
die beiden nachbarn allerdings ist
chinas geostrategische lage mit 14
nachbarn deutlich komplizierter und
erfordert eine hohe truppenstärke die
gebunden ist viel fragmentierung und
damit hohe personalausgaben und eine
komplexe logistik hinsichtlich des real
verfügbaren militärischen
investitionsbudgets und der effektiven
schlagkraft könnten japan südkorea
deswegen durchaus im vorteil sein und
was meint ihr wer sich über eine solche
bilateral allianz aus zwei demokratien
als machtfaktor in der pazifikregion
besonders freuen würde ganz klar die
verantwortlichen im us- département und
im pentagon aber auch australien das mit
hier erhebliche politische differenzen
hat würde eine derartige entwicklung
sicher mit wohlwollen sehen natürlich
ist dieses szenario noch zukunftsmusik
japan und südkorea müssen noch tiefe
gräben überwinden um sich wirklich
anzunähern china sagt dass die
zusammenarbeit mit südkorea mehr denn je
benötigt werde aber erinnert ihr euch am
anfang des videos haben wir gesagt dass
japan auch volkswirtschaftlich dabei ist
einen ganz neuen kurs einzuschlagen also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
links abgebogen
die das message ist klar sein konzept
eines kapitalismus japanischer prägung
soll einen wendepunkt einleiten doch was
genau meinte eigentlich damit nun im
grunde setzt er auf eine expansive
politik bei den öffentlichen ausgaben
dadurch würde eine größere umverteilung
erreichen und so den allgemeinen
wohlstand fördern wirtschaftsexperten
werden an dieser stelle einwenden dass
dieser ansatz total nach den alten
kenianischen formel 1 klingt die in
japan eine lange tradition haben das ist
aber nur die halbe wahrheit und wie hier
bei visual politik werden euch erklären
warum schaut euch einfach mal folgende
schlagzeilen an japans parlament
beschließt rekordhaushalt von 107
billionen yen für das jahr 2022 das
japanische parlament hat am dienstag
einen rekordhaushalt von 107 billionen
nehmen das entspricht 1 900 milliarden
us-dollar für das haushaltsjahr 2022
verabschiedet um maßnahmen gegen das
corona virus sowie steigende kosten für
die soziale sicherheit und die nationale
verteidigung zu finanzieren japans
premierminister key darstellt
konjunkturpaket im wert von 490
milliarden dollar vor das von china
vorgelegte konjunkturprogramm macht
allein mehr als 65 prozent des gesamten
budgets des konjunkturprogramms der
europäischen union nach der korona krise
aus dieser wert beeindruckt insbesondere
deswegen weil die eu etwa dreieinhalb
mal mehr einwohner hat als japan ist das
nicht eine bemerkenswerte hausnummer gut
aber neben dem enormen anstieg der
öffentlichen ausgaben ist es vielleicht
am wichtigsten wo führt die skier all
dieses geld eigentlich ausgeben will und
was noch wichtiger ist wie er das alles
finanzieren möchte
der entscheidende unterschied zwischen
china und seinen vorgängern besteht
nämlich darin dass der stadt auf
wachstumsorientierte wirtschaftsreformen
auf eine große umverteilungs kampagne
setzt so geschieht das zb die steuern
für große unternehmen und der höchsten
einkommen erhöhen und die zentralbank
weiter das zum thema mehr staatsschulden
zu finanzieren
die bereits 253 prozent des bip betragen
dies ist sowieso schon nur deswegen
möglich weil die regierung eben massive
unterstützung seitens der japanischen
zentralbank erhält und als gegenpol zu
den öffentlichen schulden die enormen
privaten ersparnisse der bevölkerung
stehen
allerdings hat genau diese geldpolitik
die jüngste krise des japanischen yen
verursacht schaut euch an japan feierte
einst einen berlin ihren jetzt sorgt das
schlimmste währungs abschluss seit 20
jahren für weit verbreitete panik 28
april bank of japan verstärkt den fall
des iren durch verschärfung ihrer ultra
lockeren politik die hauptursache der
krise war dass der ministerpräsident mit
all dem geld eine direkte finanzielle
unterstützung für haushalte mit kindern
für vollzeit und teilzeit arbeitskräfte
und auch für kleine und mittlere
unternehmen versprochen hat das alles
hört sich gar nicht mal so schlecht an
das problem bei all diesen maßnahmen ist
allerdings dass sie nie zu funktionieren
scheinen aber hey davon lässt sich
daraus jedoch nicht abschrecken lieber
versucht er immer und immer wieder das
gegenteil zu beweisen
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles der andere
aspekt diese neuen kapitalismus
japanischen stieß hat mit folgende zu
tun die schiede erfordert aggressive
lohnerhöhungen um den wohlstand
umzuverteilen
japans premierminister geschieht da ruft
ein gremium ins leben dass die
umverteilung von reichtum untersuchen
soll als rechtfertigung für eine
stärkere umverteilung und die forderung
nach höheren löhnen muss diesmal das
argument herhalten dass dies die
verbraucher nachfrage und damit sowohl
die produktion als auch die inflation
erhöhen würde denn japan befand sich
viele jahre in einer deflationsspirale
und um dies alles zu erreichen will er
zum einen den mindestlohn die renten und
die medizinische versorgung der
arbeitnehmer erhöhen zum anderen kreiert
er für lohnerhöhungen unternehmen im
gegenzug für die einführung von
steuererleichterungen
[Musik]
das problem dabei ist das japanische
unternehmen in der regel geringere
renditen vorzuweisen haben als ihre
internationalen konkurrenten und dass
das bip pro arbeitsstunde etwa 30
prozent unter den g7 durchschnitt sowie
fast 40 prozent unter den vereinigten
staaten liegt vereinfacht ausgedrückt
japan geht im internationalen vergleich
nicht sehr produktiv mit der arbeitszeit
seine arbeitnehmer oder umgekehrt diese
kriegen den lieben langen tag lang
weniger gebacken als ihre kollegen in
anderen vergleichbaren ländern tieren
liegt der grund warum keine höhere
stundenlöhne gezahlt werden und warum
der mindestlohn in den vergangenen
jahren kaum gestiegen ist diese
entwicklung hat auch damit zu tun dass
das nettovermögen der japaner in allen
schichten zuletzt stark gesunken ist mit
ausnahme der reichsten zehn prozent der
bevölkerung aber auch bei den reichsten
ist die wirtschaftliche stimmung alles
andere als euphorisch
[Musik]
außerdem wirkt die vom aktuellen
premierminister vorgeschlagene erhöhung
der kapitalertrags und dividenden steuer
die gefahr dass die investitionen ab
streckt was zu den ergebnis führen
könnte dass genau das gegenteil
erwartungen eintritt auf jeden fall
läuft im moment diese art von neuen
kapitalismus eines stils diese comics
comics oder wie auch immer ich es lernen
wollt mehr fragen auf als sie handfeste
antworten liefert in der tat wird und
einige der angekündigten maßnahmen
geradezu lächerlich 5000 geschenk an
rentner wird wohl kaum ein lächeln
hervorrufen die regierungskoalition
erwägt senioren einen pauschalen
zuschlag zukommen zu lassen um ihnen
während der pandemie beizustehen aber
die vorgeschlagene summe von 5000 yen
rund 42 us-dollar wird kaum ein lächeln
auf viele gesichter zaubern viele
menschen könnten den betrag sogar als
beleidigung empfinden bisher muss man
jedoch sagen dass die schüler mit dieser
politik beim wahlvolk außerordentlich
beliebt ist zum zeitpunkt ist richtiges
videos und wenige tage vor den wichtigen
wahlen zum japanischen oberhaus genießt
der premierminister die höchsten
zustimmungswerte seit seinem amtsantritt
vor acht monaten und wir denken dass ihr
unsere werten visual politik zuschauer
allein schon deswegen unbedingt die
strategie das kennen solltet wenn diese
wird unserer ansicht nach das
geopolitische gefüge in der region und
weltweit nachhaltig und in vielen
bereichen beeinflussen militärausgaben
drastisch erhöhen die beziehungen zu
südkorea und den usa spürbar verbessern
und japans einfluss in der
internationalen politik zu einem
ordentlichen schub verhelfen
gleichzeitig soll die japanische
wirtschaft durch eine kombination aus
staatlichen anreizen eine ausweitung der
geldmenge neue schulden und inflation
gedrückt werden all diese entwicklungen
werden wir dann in weiterführende videos
auseinandernehmen damit ihr ein
geschlossenes gesamtbild bekommt
vergesst also bitte nicht das abo und
vor allem das glöckchen um keines
unserer videos zu verpassen ich danke
euch und bis dahin seid ihr erstmal mit
eurer meinung an der reihe wird japan zu
einer supermacht im asiatisch
pazifischen raum was haltet ihr von den
revolutionären plänen des neuen
premierministers könnten die ausgabe
orgien seine tatsächlichen
handlungsspielraum mehr einschränken wie
lange kann er sich überhaupt im amt
halten und welches land wird sich eurer
meinung nach besser entwickeln japan
oder südkorea unter seinem neuen
präsidenten juden über den wir das die
video machen werden wie immer sind wir
schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ergebnis das mit einem freund
unvergessliches aber mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
und eine spende von euch mit dem es hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen denn peter
link dazu findet ihr wie immer in der
beschreibung über den video maß gut und
ist bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]